wildfires near greece's capital athens
have forced people to evacuate their
homes they were apparently sparked by a
blaze at a power station with strong
winds then fanning those flames
concerns are rising there could be a
repeat of last summer when fires
devastated more than 125 000 hectares
desperate attempts to save their homes
from the approaching flames local
residents are rushing to help
firefighters in this athens suburb
but the wildfires are spreading fast due
to strong winds and hot summer weather
the fire brigade is getting air support
as the blaze makes its way towards empty
houses
people here were told to leave after the
first signs of the fires appeared
we received a message from the ministry
that we need to evacuate our homes so we
did and we are now watching from a
distance we were scared a bit but now i
think the situation is better
but the damage is done
in another neighborhood residents
returned to discover their homes were
hit by the flames
and their cars destroyed
the battle continues on the slopes of a
nearby mountain recalling scenes from
last summer
back then a heat wave which authorities
attribute to climate change triggered
the country's worst wildfires in more
than a decade
after they exposed its poor resources
greece is this year trying to prepare
itself better and the eu has promised
help with more than 200 firefighters and
equipment soon to be deployed to the
country
that leaves people here wondering if
that would be enough if the fires come
back on a similar scale this summer
you